welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to CBS has just dropped the trailer
for their upcoming horror scary stories
to tell in the dark and throughout this
video we'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the film
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
want to go into the movie as blind as
possible then I highly recommend that
you turn off now for everyone else sit
back relax and let's dive into my
breakdown of the scary stories to tell
in the darker trailer the trailer opens
with the haunting voice of Sarah bellows
who says this town has told stories
about me referring to the town of Mill
Valley a picturesque 1950s American town
which is the setting for the film
however she rebuts it by stating that
she has some stories over wrong which is
when the children who are the
protagonists of the film discover her
book the film centers around these kids
who've been brought together to solve
the mystery of a bunch of horrific
murders that have happened in the town
and this is the main thrust of the plot
we are then given glimpses at the
monsters as they slowly begin to track
down and terrorize the children it seems
to be pretty closely playing to the
original source material and for those
who don't know scary stories to tell in
the dark is a series of children's
horror books written by Alvin Schwartz
and illustrated by Stephen Gamal
Guillermo del Toro is really going back
to his childhood with this one and from
the tone of the trailer it seems that
this is going to be more than just a
kids movie the film itself appears to be
adapting certain aspects of the book and
putting them together in one single
narrative which I'll now go into the
first story that appears to have made
its way to the big screen is the big toe
this short tale is arguably one of the
source materials most famous and it
follows the tale of a young boy who due
to starvation eats a toe which he finds
on the ground this puts the toes owner a
decrepit old woman on the quest for
revenge because hey who wants their big
toe even as she tracks him down she gets
it back in more ways than one
once it's unlikely that the
cannibalistic elements will make it to
the movie it does appear that the story
will still derive heavily from the
original another character that is
definitely hitting cinemas is the pale
lady this grotesque
bloated and monstrous woman can be seen
stalking our characters one night in an
empty school
don't let her wait make you feel like
she'll be easy to get away from though
as the pale lady is able to teleport and
this makes her a pretty hard boat to
escape from the pale lady comes from a
story in which she haunts a girl's
dreams stalking her throughout it and
grabbing her arm in real life to wake
her up next up is the red spot which in
the trailer seems to be taking place in
the same location as the pale lady in
that story after a girl is bitten on the
cheek by a spider she comes to realize
that one has in fact impregnated her and
at the end of the story a group of
spiders come crawling out of her face
which I'll get into more later next up
is Harold now Harold is arguably the
trailer's biggest selling point this
gruesome scarecrow is currently making
up a lot of the marketing material and
seems to be the film's main focus right
now so it's fair to say that he will
play a big part Harold in the boot comes
alive and skins one of the farmers that
owns him and this could potentially
kick-start the murders in the town and
will probably be how the film opens last
but not least is the janky man this is a
completely new creation for the film and
he seems to be attacking the children in
some sort of bond this could link to the
form that the murders by Harold happened
on and it would make sense for the teens
to visit this location the janky man
also has huge spider like arms and he
could even be a fully grown version of
the spiders that crawl out of the girl's
face in the red spot which would into
either stories for an overall narrative
the last shot of the trailer appears to
show the ghost of Sarah bellows and it
makes sense to have her in the film as
this ultimately seems like her quest for
a revenge against the town that hated
her was that don't think she will kill
the kids the adults are fair game and it
would be awesome if she laid the town of
runes in the film's final moments so
that's everything you need to know about
the movie if I missed anything then make
sure you let me know in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of this week's big
release Shazam
which would be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]